>>> THERE IS SOME MAJOR MOVEMENT
HAPPENING IN UKRAINE.
UKRAINIAN TROOPS LIBERATING
STRATEGIC TOWNS IN THE EASTERN
DONETSK REGION.
SOLDIERS RAISING THE UKRAINIAN
FLAG OVER THE CITY OF LYMAN
AFTER RUSSIA CLAIMED THEY WERE
ANNEXED.
RUSSIA IS ACKNOWLEDGING THE
ADVANCES WHICH IS SURPRISING.
BUT THERE ARE ALSO REPORTING OF
RUSSIANS GOING DOOR-TO-DOOR IN
OCCUPIED AREAS OF UKRAINE
LOOKING NOW FOR YOUNG MEN TO
ENLIST IN THEIR FIGHT.
TODAY RUSSIA'S LEGISLATURE IS
BEGINNING THE PROCESS OF
APPROVING PRESIDENT PUTIN'S
PLANS TO ANNEX THESE FOUR KEY
PARTS OF UKRAINE.
JOINING ME NOW ON THIS VERY
LATEST HERE IS CNN MILITARY
ANALYST RETIRED GENERAL WESLEY
CLARK, A FORMER NATO ALLIED
COMMANDER AND STEVE HALL, A CIA
FORMER CHIEF OF RUSSIA
OPERATIONS.
IT IS GOOD TO SEE YOU BOTH.
GENERAL, WHO DO YOU MAKE OF THE
CLAIMS THAT PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY
IS THAT TROOPS ARE REGAINING
GROUND IN THE VERY SAME PLACES
THAT PUTIN IS CLAIMING NOW IS
PART OF RUSSIA?
>> I THINK IT IS A VERY
HEARTENING TO SEE THE GAINS THE
UKRAINIANS HAVE MADE.
THE CONCERN IS DON'T GO TOO
FAST.
DON'T OUTRUN YOUR SUPPLIES.
DON'T OUTRUN YOUR
REINFORCEMENTS.
KEEP STEADY PRESSURE ON.
STEADY WIN THIS IS RACE.
>> STEVE, PUTIN IS TRYING TO
CLAIM NOW THAT AN AREA, THAT AN
ATTACK IN THESE AREAS IS
ESSENTIALLY AND DIRECTLY AN
ATTACK ON RUSSIA.
IS WHAT PUTIN IS TRYING TO SAY.
I WANT TO PLAY FOR YOU HOW WHITE
HOUSE SPOKESPERSON JOHN KIRBY
RESPONDED TO THIS TODAY.
>> IT IS NOT AN ATTACK ON
RUSSIA.
IT IS UKRAINIAN SOIL.
IT WAS UKRAINIAN SOIL.
IT IS TODAY.
AND IT WILL BE TOMORROW.
AND WE'RE NOT IN THE BUSINESS OF
TELLING PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY HOW
HE GOES ABOUT CONDUCTING
MILITARY OPERATIONS.
WHAT WE ARE DOING IS MAKING SURE
HE HAS THE CAPABILITIES AND
ASSISTANCE THAT HE NEEDS TO DO
THAT EFFECTUALLY AND HE IS.
>> AND DOES THIS CHANGE ANYTHING
ABOUT HOW RUSSIA WILL RESPOND
WHEN UKRAINIANS DO ATTACK?
>> I'M NOT SURE, KATE, THAT IT
WILL.
I THINK WHAT HAS HAPPENED THAT
PUTIN TRIED TO DO THIS
BAIT-AND-SWITCH, NOW THIS IS ALL
MINE AND HE DOESN'T CONTROL THAT
TERRITORY FULLY SO IT IS
DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
REASONABLE PERSON WOULD THINK
THAT HE COULD ANNEX SOMETHING
THAT HE DOESN'T CONTROL.
BUT NOW, I I'M NOT SURE THAT IT
WILL CHANGE THINGS.
THE MOST EFFECTIVE THING THAT
PUTIN HAS DONE SO FAR IS NUCLEAR
SABER RATTLING.
HE HE CAN'T USE THOSE WITHOUT
PAYING A EXTREMELY HIGH PRICE.
SO HE'S MAKING US WORRIED ABOUT
IT AND IF WE MOVED INTO THE
AREAS WHICH THEY HAVE ANNEXED,
WOULD HE CONSIDER SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
THAT IS HIS STRONGEST OPTION
RIGHT NOW.
>> I DO WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
THAT.
BUT ONE CONSIDERATION OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AROUND
SUPPLYING WEAPONS TO UKRAINE ALL
ALONG IS NOT WANTING TO BE SEEN
AS A DIRECT PARTY TO THE
CONFLICT.
AND IN DIRECT CONFLICT WITH
RUSSIA IF YOU WILL.
ALEX MARQUARDT MY COLLEAGUE IS
REPORTING AS A WAY TO OVERCOME
U.S. RESISTANCE TO SUPPLYING A
CERTAIN LONGER RANGE ROCKET
SYSTEM, UKRAINE IS OFFERING THE
U.S. FULL VISIBILITY INTO THEIR
LIST OF RUSSIAN TARGETS GIVING
THE U.S. VETO POWER AND WHAT DO
WE NEED TO KNOW ABOUT THIS
MISSILE SYSTEM, THE ARMY
TACTICAL MISSILE SYSTEMS THAT
UKRAINE IS ASKING FOR?
>> WELL AS FAR AS PUTIN IS
CONCERNED, WE'RE DIRECTLY
INVOLVED.
SO WE'RE PLAYING A GAME WITH OUR
OWN POPULATION HERE.
BUT IT IS WORLD WAR III AGAINST
US AND NATO.
SO WE'RE ONLY FOOLING OURSELVES.
I THINK IT IS WONDERFUL THAT
UKRAINIANS WILL EXPOSE OUR LIST
AND THEY KNOW MORE THAN WE DO
AND THEY HAVE TO BE CAREFUL
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE ONES, IT IS
THEIR TERRITORY AND THEIR LIVES
THAT ARE BEING SPENT.
AND SO GOT TO RESPECT WHAT
THEY'RE DOING.
I'M GOING TO TELL YOU, WE NEED
THOSE ATTACK-EMS IN THERE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS SAID NO.
BUT WE NEED THE SWITCHBLADE 600s
AND THEY'VE BEEN HELD UP FOR SIX
MONTHS IN VARIOUS BUREAUCRATIC
SNAFUS INSIDE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION.
AND THOSE DRONES, THOSE KILLER
DRONES THAT WE'RE GOING TO PUT
IN THERE ARE CRITICAL.
THEY COULD DO SOME OF THE SAME
THINGS THAT THE ATTACKS COULD
DO.
NOT AS FAR AS THEY'RE VERY
EFFECTIVE GOING ACROSS THE LINES
AND THEY NEED THESE WEAPONS IN
UKRAINE.
SO, I HOPE WE'RE GOING TO
ACCELERATE AND EXPEDITE WHAT
WE'RE GIVING TO UKRAINES.
THEY HAVE MOMENTUM.
THIS IS THE TIME TO DO IT.
>> AND YOU TALKED ABOUT NUCLEAR
SABER RATTLES AND WITH CONCERNS
NOW GROWING THAT PUTIN WILL
ESCALATE TO USING NUCLEAR
WEAPONS SH THE WHITE HOUSE IS
WARNING AND THE GENERALLY SAYING
SAY OVER AND OVER AGAINST,
CONSEQUENCES WILL BE FOLLOW.
BE SURE OF THAT.
I WANT TO PLAY WHAT GENERAL
PETRAEUS SAID THOSE CONSEQUENCES
COULD BE.
>> JUST TO GIVE YOU A
HYPOTHETICAL.
WE WOULD RESPOND BY LEADING A
NATO, A COLLECTIVE EFFORT THAT
WOULD TAKE OUT EVERY RUSSIAN
CONVENTION FORCE THAT WE COULD
SEE AND IDENTIFY ON THE
BATTLEFIELD IN UKRAINE AND ALSO
IN CRIMEA AND EVERY SHIP ON THE
BLACK SEA.
>> IF THAT IS WHAT IS BEING
CONSIDERED IN RESPONSE, STEVE,
HOW DOES VLADIMIR PUTIN RECEIVE
THAT?
>> VLADIMIR PUTIN IS IN A
DIFFICULT POSITION WITH HIS
NUCLEAR WEAPONS AS I INDICATED
EARLIER.
THESE ARE SORT OF THE WEAPONS
THAT HE DARE NOT USE UNLESS HE
IS WILLING TO FULLY DEAL WITH
THE CONSEQUENCES.
WHICH OF COURSE COULD RESULT IN
ANYTHING FROM A SIGNIFICANT
NON-NUCLEAR RESPONSE FROM THE
WEST, POTENTIALLY A NUCLEAR
RESPONSE FROM THE WEST, BUT THE
THING THAT HE ALSO HAS TO
CONSIDER IS THE PRICE THAT HE
WOULD PAY BOTH INTERNALLY AND
INTERNATIONALLY FOR USE OF ANY
WEAPON, WHETHER IT WAS LOW YIELD
OR WHETHER IT WAS STRATEGIC.
I MEAN, CHINA AND INDIA HAVE
EXPRESSED GRAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THAT AND I IMAGINE THERE ARE
FOLKS WITHIN THE KREMLIN THAT
SAY WE HAVE TO BE CAREFUL FOR
THIS.
SO IT IS FRUSTRATING FOR
VLADIMIR PUTIN THAT HE HAS